death reception in the jumping spider  appears to rely on a layer of green  pigment in the spiders retina in the  first image you can see the experimental  setup used to capture videos of the  spiders under different light conditions  jumping spiders have two pairs of  forward-facing eyes principal eyes and  anterior lateral eyes  under normal light using only one  principle I the spiders were able to  accurately pounce on a fruit fly under  green light the spiders are still able  to judge the distance to their prey  easily in the red light condition the  spiders jumps are short of their targets  showing that they need the green light  in order to perceive depth correctly